now what shouldn't be lost on you is in
any of the viewers is that the special
councils original mandate was to find
out what Russia did to influence the
2016 election now to date there's still
been no evidence presented by the mother
team that any criminal collusion
occurred between Trump folks and the
Russian government so perhaps the
chattering class can breathe a little
bit before we make any grand
declarations about where this invest
investigation is actually going but for
more insight we put together a super
panel of experts we're gonna provide you
with all the answers you need to know so
low Eisenberg former deputy independent
counsel during the Whitewater
investigation James trustees former DOJ
attorney in the criminal division and
here with me in studio house Intel
member Michael Turner and John Solomon
investigative reporter an opinion
contributor of the hill let's start with
you congressman where we are right now
is seems like leaps and bounds beyond
what we were led to believe when this
entire thing kicked off when Jeff
Sessions recuse --is Rosenstein steps in
seems to have a real meltdown decides
got appoint a special counsel and here
we are all this time later with like a
72 year old guy you know looks like he
might you know get charged with
something all Roger stone kicking around
and now we have this this deal with
Michael Cohen well well you have an
excellent point about what the original
mandate was of the special counsel and
when the news first broke it looked like
it was you know an exciting story about
Michael Cohen and being you know coming
forward the guilty plea about lying
but when upon further investigation
what's really notable here is that in
the written statement that he actually
gave to the Senate he made a statement
that he was not involved in collusion
with Russia the Russian Federation and
it involved in any way in any hacking
that is not a statement that he pled
guilty to today or Moeller teamer
special counsel alleged was false so
here you have a statement that actually
relates to the mandate of the
investigation that's not the subject
matter of an alleged lie at this point
and you have that the investigation and
the the marching in of the guilty plea
over a failed real estate deal not the
same thing not what we're looking for if
the if the special counsel
information that that this was a a false
statement from Michael Cohen you would
have expected that it would've been part
of the guilty plea today so the false
statement 18 USD thousand and one it's a
classic go to charge in these types of
cases you don't lie don't tell lies to a
prosecutor you get in big trouble when
you do but it's also a tool the cynics
would say people don't want to be in
jail for the next 60 years and you get
your sentence reduced if you well maybe
I guess I wasn't completely forthcoming
on that how do you see this Michael
Cohen announcement today fitting into
this overall narrative if you actually
look Laura at the plea agreement and at
the criminal information there's
absolutely nothing that implicit
implicates President Trump in a crime
there's absolutely nothing in there that
says where Michael Cohen says President
Trump talked with me about the lie I was
going to tell to Congress we conspired
we talked about it there's nothing
whatsoever so if we really confine
ourselves to the act actual law and not
a bunch of babble that you hear all day
on television let's just look at the
actual documents it it doesn't implicate
President Trump in any way which brings
up the question of why he was so angry
if he's been told about this and why he
came out and said Cohen's nothing but a
liar he's lying all Cohen said is that I
I lied to Congress he didn't say that
President Trump helped me lie so there
could be all kinds of things that Muller
is keeping quiet from us that we don't
know about that Cohen has told him
that's possible but that's the real most
speculation let's talk about reality and
reality is this is a nothing burger but
John Solomon to listen to congressman on
the other side of the aisle today
Eric's wall well one of our favorites I
want you to listen to what he said about
where this is all going all right I
believe they are obstructing the
collusion and again this is where Donald
Trump will say oh they're just trying
you know to bring them up on lies well
only guilty people lie and what they are
trying to protect is that the president
his family his businesses and his
campaigns sawed dirt on Hillary Clinton
from the Russians and sought to do a big
deal in Moscow at the time of the
campaign and when they were confronted
about it they like where I come from
that's collusion John I don't know where
it comes from but it is in collusion
let's take a look at what happened today
the president's attorney admitted to
lying about a business deal that would
have been perfectly legal may be stupid
but perfectly legal if it went through
he doesn't implicate the president at
all and and I think more importantly
people are missing the significance of
why this happened today
Bob mother waited in wait to see what
the president would say and his answer
is to see if he could catch them in a
perjury trap he didn't the president
answered in a way that was consistent
with the evidence so that he's cleaning
up now and finishing up his Cohen
investigation that's what went on today
now James how would you as a as a
prosecutor and the Criminal Division
treat a witness like Cohen who's
obviously he was trading on the
president's name he strikes me as
somebody who loved being close to power
and he no Trump obviously helped him as
the president said Ron if that what a
big favorite years ago but how do you
treat him given his admitted
slipperiness with the truth and the
facts right well look you have to go
into it knowing that you're kind of
engaging in snake wrestling and as much
as as a private attorney as a defense
attorney I would relish the idea of
cross-examining this guy I mean he's a
he's a lawyer who betrayed his client
who said he'd take a bullet didn't mean
that has now admitted criminal
culpability that is his own culpability
and now he's trying to get a break from
the judge so there's a million very
stock great things you can cross-examine
on but I have to say some of the
prosecutors on that team know their way
around the courthouse you know Greg
Andres would put mobsters on the stand
who had a lot of baggage too so they're
not blind to the fact that this guy is
kind of a horrible character and not
instantly likable bye-bye many outside
his family and James tape recordings he
has tape recordings apparently well
that's the thing if we don't know what
he has either documents we don't but if
he has emails documents some powerful
Rober Asian you might actually be able
to overcome all of the initial dislike
and and more importantly disbelief of
Michael Cohen that you're gonna have as
a juror yeah but we won't play but even
though you have Jake Tapper today saying
I don't see any where's the collusion
with the president means is all
interesting but again we don't know
completely what they have we don't know
yet
congressman I want to talk for a moment
about what happened today with Co me
because hidden like this idea coming in
and talking to you guys in closed
session he sent out tweet today my legal
team filed court papers to try to get
transparency from House Republicans let
the American people watch so then he can
get that what does he say nauseated he
was nauseous it makes me nauseous so
that made me nauseous to see because you
guys are the ones who have a problem
with transparency that's rich coming
from Co me right this is not about
transparency there's about stall tactics
and stall tactics only Jerry Nadler the
incoming Democratic chairman of the
committee said in according to Bloomberg
today that this is about trying to punt
this over so that perhaps the the
subpoena can be averted the reality is
is that Comey is free in the public to
say whatever statement that he wants to
make and and the he doesn't get to
choose under what forum Congress calls
him forward
so what's gonna what's that what's gonna
happen next I mean there's no hopefully
the court process will work quickly a
five minutes left in and well there will
not be you know an impediment to this
going forward to subpoena from Congress
should be a subpoena that stands and he
should come forward and testify so in
coming house judiciary chair Nadler said
the following today anyone who still
believes that this is a witch hunt must
now face the reality that the
investigation appears to be closing in
on the president
so I'll given what we know now what
about that statement well number one
I've never thought it was a witch hunt
but there's certainly nothing again in
in the official papers that have been
released that we look at which is how
Muller explains things to people that
would indicate that they are closing in
on the president I'd like to make
another point Co about Cohen Cohen's
case has already been his Muller case
has already been reassigned to the New
York judge who handled his original case
now
the plea the sentencing range in his
case in New York was with the Southern
District was 46 to 57 months could be as
high as 63 months by consolidating these
for sentencing he has the potential to
actually get probation because Muller is
giving him a 5k one for cooperation
which is a very significant thing and so
they are consolidated for sentencing
that judge in the New York case in the
Southern District case will sentence
together there's a whole grouping
concept in the guidelines and at the end
of the day can say wow your cooperation
with Muller was so great you're going
all the way down to probation now his
attorneys could have argued for that
anyway but when that when you have a 5k
one from the government that's a huge
thing so keep keep your eye on that well
we're working on booking him so thank
you we prefer to interview him in studio
and not in jail so thank you so much